last weekend we were talking about the
enormous strain on the nhs
as a result of rising coronavirus cases
now that pressure has not gone away but
it does seem the rate of infections
may be slowing well let's talk to our
first guest about that imperial college
london professor
azra ghani thank you so much for being
on the program
the last thing i want to do is to
underplay the deaths we're seeing
the hospitalizations we're seeing the
cases we're still seeing
but is there the beginning of
a [ __ ] of light at the end of the
tunnel starting to appear
yes absolutely agree we're in a very
difficult situation at the moment and
the nhs is possibly
um at um it's worse that we've seen
um so far during this pandemic and
indeed in recent history
so it is important to note that we have
started to see a small decline
in cases in some areas and so that is
certainly positive news that the current
restrictions that are in place
are having the effect that we hoped it's
very important over the coming weeks
that people adhere to these restrictions
and we continue to see the cases decline
we expect to then start to see decreases
in hospitalizations
uh coming through in the in the next
week or two
is it the current restrictions that
we're starting to have an impact that
the full national lockdown or
all the older restrictions that we saw
the sort of tier four if you like
well both will have had some effect in
slowing the uh growth in cases
the most important thing that we're
seeing now is actually a decline in case
numbers
and that's what we really need to
accelerate as far as possible because
this
is of course saving people's lives and
avoiding
unnecessary illness for all of these
individuals have been infected
it's a very difficult disease to deal
with there's been lots of talk
almost every news conference they're
asked you know when will the
restrictions end when
will we get back to normal so i'm
interested to get your view on that
will it be when a certain number of
people are vaccinated you think or
when case numbers decline to a certain
amount and when roughly i know it's very
hard to say but when roughly do you
think that could be
well it is a combination of exactly
those two things the first thing we need
to focus on right now is getting
those case numbers down really we want
to get back to the situation we were in
the summer
with relatively low case numbers
compared to now
so that we can actually test and trace
and
reduce onward infections at the same
time we're of course
rolling out a vaccine that's something
we haven't had up until now and that
vaccine rollout is going very well that
will hopefully
protect those that are most vulnerable
um to the severe
consequences of this disease and but
we'll need to get a balance of these two
things in place
before we can start to lift restrictions
and it's very difficult to say exactly
when that will be
chris whittie the um chief medical
officer has said that covert could
become seasonal a bit like flu
do you think that we could see a
situation where restrictions are or some
restrictions are reimposed around the
winter months
it's possible i think we're very much
hoping that the vaccine will
enable us really to go back to as normal
a life as possible but we have to
remember that the virus is still
circulating globally
and even if the uk is fully vaccinated
it's likely that we will get
importations continue
and so that's why it's also incredibly
important that we support
wider efforts to ensure vaccination is
available to all countries not just
uh those that are able to to pay in this
first phase
and how um much do you support the
recent news we had that actually the
border restrictions are being tightened
up do you think that should have been
done sooner
um well we know that the virus is
circulating everywhere and we also know
that these
mutations these changes in the virus are
happening all the time
and so it's very difficult to predict
where these new issues will arise we've
clearly had one of these
so-called variants of concern in the uk
um others have merged in south africa
and brazil
but anticipating where those changes
will happen
is impossible to do and so i think we'll
have to take some pragmatic
approaches in the short term closing
borders obviously
helps prevent more of those infections
um coming in
to the uk but as we get the vaccine roll
out
and continued surveillance and
monitoring of
the strains that are circulating and we
will be able to for example tweak the
vaccines
um to make sure that we remain protected
good news about of course the ability to
hopefully tweak
the vaccine and and i know how
unpredictable the disease is but at the
same time it was quite predictable as
you say that the virus will mutate
i'm struggling to understand why the
border restrictions weren't toughened up
sooner i mean you're not you're not you
don't even have to show that you've had
a negative test until tomorrow um well
again we've got the virus circulating
here so these mutations could of course
happened in the uk and indeed have
happened in the uk um so it is really a
balance that has to be made from
an epidemiologist's point of view we of
course want to try and restrict
importations as much as we want to try
and reduce the levels of transmission
occurring locally
but there are wider balances to be made
in terms of the impact that this has
on people's lives and livelihoods and
that is therefore a political
decision um the vaccine of course um
is a really good piece of news that
we've had recently it feels
like the role art is tentatively going
quite well i mean the official target is
to vaccinate
all over 50s shielders people who work
in the nhs and care homes by the end of
april
from what you've seen are you hopeful
that it might actually happen sooner
than that
i think that remains a sensible target
given the rollout so far
and we obviously have exceeded the
levels of around 2 million a week that
we were initially
aiming for and therefore the hope is
that most vulnerable will be protected
in the near term we have to remember um
that once we get towards springtime we
also have to
um give those second doses out so
essentially the numbers will need to
double to ensure that people become
fully protected
and if we do get to a situation where we
have vaccinated the most vulnerable
vaccine to the people who are most
likely to get sick
very sick if they get covered 19. is
that a point when it's acceptable to
start
lifting restrictions and allowing the
virus to circulate among younger people
it will be a combination of having those
people protected but also of course
trying to reduce transmission as much as
we can in the in the interim
and because there is a balance between
these two things and
it we have to remember that many of the
people in hospital
are indeed younger than um even 50 years
of age and we do want to protect
the whole population and then just
finally i want to ask you about the
spacing
between doses the uk's obviously decided
to space out
the time that people can receive the
first and second dose up to 12 weeks
is there a risk that the virus may be
more likely to mutate
given the spacing um
the spacing um is based on uh data it's
certainly for the oxford asparsenica
vaccine
and in that they showed that the
efficacy did remain high
between initial dose and right out to 12
weeks
and if that high efficacy remains in
place then we don't have any concern
about
specific mutations occurring to the
virus in that period
the fighter vaccine we don't have as
much data but it did show very
strong efficacy um from 12 days
following the first dose
right through to the second dose being
given at 21 days
um and so the other measurements that we
have on that vaccine and the wider
understanding is that it's likely that
there would remain very high efficacy
and as if the vaccine
is highly efficacious then that reduces
the risk of these mutations occurring it
doesn't
ever exclude them and we may of course
need to adapt vaccines going forwards